[Music]
for you I would think you look so
different in real life than from your
character yes that it might be I mean if
you look a picture of your character and
then you've got you guys here see she
gets a bigger cheer then ah no no you
you're absolutely stunning but I could
see you being able to go through life
and maybe not get recognized yes that
character people would say oh my god
who's that beautiful woman but they
might not think you're the Khaleesi you
know yeah no no I don't get recognized
truly it's I'll be walking with Kit
Harington plays on snow or Gwen who
plays Brienne of Tarth or something like
that and they will be people to be like
all can you take this picture for us I'm
like so definitely I again sure I can
they hand you the camera and me the
count has no idea what they're did that
so inside uh no way yeah it's quite an
eye here especially I'll go into there
like I'll be like kit just dream woman
I'm just gonna go into the loo and then
I'll hear these girls being like who is
that girl at his with me he has some
dragons again your face off likely why
is she drinking blood and we are now you
shoot Game of Thrones in croatia and
spain yes
is that right last couple seasons have
been that you ever hang out with the
locals and if so are the locals who are
hanging out are they Game of Thrones
fans cuz Game of Thrones are very
serious oh yeah yeah yeah well in the
beginning especially in Croatia we could
we could chill and it was fine but then
there was one very yeah everyone very
silly day when myself and Natalie
Emmanuel who plays missandei on the show
and we were we had just got to the hotel
is little small one we're just we're
just gonna go downstairs and get some
water or something and we're going down
on the left and we're like what is that
music
the doors open to the theme tune of Game
of Thrones like if the doors open as I
turned they don't know what it's a game
of Thrones themed wedding oh my god
happening in the hotel in the hotel
you're staying in I'm in the hotel like
Peters gonna walk in at any point I'm
like we need to we need to warn him
there's a game of Thrones themes yeah
and we would literally the lifts out the
doors open and we were like oh might we
need to back out and back out quickly
that way
that's so funny that your instincts the
exact opposite from mine mine would be
I'm getting in there like a yeah Conan
theme I'm here you know we are gathered
here today yeah giving her away or
something no but you know what if you
had gone they would have insisted you'd
have to do a selfie with every single
okay no we hid we because then it got
kind of to the point where we would like
hide in the corridor because everyone
was like day and people a yeah did Peter
Dinklage ever did he show up at that
hotel uh-huh and then we were just chill
in the corridor with like a bottle of
wine being like this is the saddest days
of our life I love that all of us have
seen you guys confront the greatest
scariest things in the world and what
terrifies you most fans in a hotel lobby
no I mean auntie you know oh yeah that
yes it was scary it was Gary it was
funny we just went to commercial and
Andy leaned over because we were talking
about this game of Thrones wedding and
Andy made the point that there's never
been a happy wedding on Game of Thrones
it is the worst show to base your
wedding on yeah you know it's obviously
much every single wedding is horrible
t-there completely unwanted or people
get slaughtered yeah yeah those are the
two choices yeah
you